Nó chận lúc quan sảy ra vào ngày 12, của vực đội 5-3 tháng vẫn bị muôn đất buổi lấp dài.
Như đoạn của lộ 3-2 bị sạch lượng vừa học nghiêm chào,
hàng chục máy sức mấy uổi của một lộ bộ đội công an và người dân đang tập trung sọng sẽ đất đá.
Khoi thông tối đồng với mặt nối hàng nội, bởi các tình cuối thoại lào cai và lai châu.
Lúc quên đá cuốn theo lượng lớn đất đá và kỷ gỗ,
làm nhiều nha bị sạch thương học năng.
Dên sả mừng thành có mối 1 muôn nhà bị sạch hoàn toàn.
Mới 1 nhà hơn hàng chim bệnh miệng phần chăm và mười lắm các nhà hữu hàng một phần.
Nếu dễn tích lỗi vụ muôn tại các bạn chết, đội chiến độ bị một và sắp muộ.
Cũng bị đất đá vụ lấp.
Thìa thải nạn này, người lượng chương năng tích tụi đồng nhăn lực phương tiện khắp phục phộ quà,
đồng thời chiến khai tình kiếm bộ người còn đá mất tích.
Thế nhìn định mang đau trận lúc quái tình thành từ khu vực nối cao thủ giải hoa linh sân.
Nơi sất hiện nhiều điểm sạch lượng.
Nếu lúc quán theo đất đá từ thượng muôn độ xuống khu vân cơ,
người thị thải nếu trọng với nhà cửa hạ tân và sạch sóa.